from red carpets to royalty to dressing
her bum Meghan's fashion has evolved a
lot here is every fabulous pregnancy
style she's rocked until now
[Music]
I think it's also made me sort of go
outside of the box a little bit I've
have a better knowledge of other
designers to the former actress credits
playing Rachel lien on suits with
teaching her a thing or two about
fashion but whatever the reason we can't
get enough of her looks like this
whimsical animal and floral chiffon
oscar de la renta midi she recently wore
during a visit to a boxing charity
organization with Prince Harry the
unique dress features everything from
birds to flowers and even a radish
but it's the sara flynt sweet knee boots
that really have us green with envy
in January the mom-to-be blew us away in
a navy sequined gown by roland Marais at
the London premiere of Cirque de Soleil
totem she paired the perfect party look
with Stuart Weitzman heels a Givenchy
clutch and Princess Diana's gold
bracelet and Meg gave us all the Diana
vibes again with this bold color
combination of red and purple there's
another celebration going on and it's
not a party in the traditional sense
it's among designers who are celebrating
the Megan effect a phenomenon worth
everything
this Duchess touches turns to gold one
of our favorites is the floral number
Megan wore during a stop at the Royal
Variety residential nursing and care
home in December the gorgeous pale
floral midi brought collection dress
with cap sleeves chic grey coat and
taupe aquas our heels meet her bump the
center of attention it is beautiful as
you remember goodness amazing isn't it
but Megan was radiant as she took the
stage to honor her wedding dress
designer Javon she's clear wait Keller
at the British Fashion Awards wearing a
sleek black one-shoulder Giovani she
gown and here she is looking brilliant
in a Club Monaco coat and dress while
visiting the hub community kitchen the
day before Thanksgiving her belly is
barely there GLAAD is so present it is
incredibly on trend the brown plaid
Karen Walker trench coat she wore as she
kicked off her first day in New Zealand
sent us screaming for our trenches the
gorgeous custom white cap sleeved gown
by thea megan wore at a state dinner in
Tonga was an elegant statement dress
accessorized by her tiny baby bump as
Yvonne she clutched and aqua Zara pumps
completed her look but it's Princess
Diana's aquamarine ring the same one Meg
wore to her evening wedding reception
that really caught our eye
and can we say vision in blue and
another state dinner on the royal tour
this one in Fiji how would you describe
your personal style I like to look
polished and put together but there's
always going to be like an effortless
quality to it just being from LA Megan
gave off all the effortlessly chic vibes
during a few more outdoorsy stops in the
land down under this reformation dressed
Anders striped maxi by Martin grant just
scream California Megan clearly knows
the power of celebrity there is Megan
and how it can help small brands make
big impressions we loved how the Duchess
wore her gal pal Serena Williams
collection on her fall royal tour her
oversized checkered blazer reminded us
of what a champion she is for her
friends and who could forget the
stunning white Karen Jie dress Megan
wore the day we learned she was
expecting one of my closest girlfriends
is here jessica Mulrooney who runs
Kleinfelds in toronto
now rumor has it jessica has been the
one responsible for Megan's
groundbreaking fashion but ET recently
learned the Duchess does everything
herself quote she does her own makeup
with the exception of her wedding day
she styles herself for engagements black
ties for all of them
[Music]